the interesting thing to think about
when you think about technology is what
is your goal when you use a connective
device you're reaching outward you're
going beyond yourself and your limited
world that you live in to connect to
other people to connect the information
you otherwise wouldn't be able to reach
and that's a wonderful thing obviously
it's almost miraculous the amount of
information and the number of people
that we have at our fingertips today but
the question is what's your goal in
reaching outward like that in immersing
yourself in the outward world I think
most of us are seeking to enrich
ultimately our in word world to make
ourselves happier to be more fulfilled
in life to really reach those goals that
we're all trying to reach in our lives
whatever they happen to be in their
different for every person so the
balance that people really have always
learned to strike through history with
new connective devices is to figure out
how you use a new technology to go out
into that outward world and bring it
back home so that you can use it in a
reflective way so that you can take it
to that place that I refer to in my book
is depth you know you really want to
have in everything you do in your work
and your relationships you want it to be
experiences that have real depth so that
they are adding to your life rather than
subtracting to it and my belief in the
book and I work very hard to establish
this to historical examples as well as
contemporary ones is that if you spend
all your time in the outward world all
your time extending your consciousness
and your senses into that realm beyond
the here and now you can never get to
that deep place because you're allowing
your inner life to atrophy really to
wither and that's a very high price to
pay I think we've all been feeling all
of us who have been connected in a big
way in the last couple decades and I
know I have been have been feeling that
and that's sort of this anxiety that you
can feel seeping up in society where
people are beginning to view their
handhelds and other devices not so much
as the friends we thought they were
seven or eight years ago but they're
beginning to feel like enemies in a way
and burdens
yeah I think that um I think that we are
wrestling with intimacy today I don't
want to say we're rethinking it because
I think intimacy is intimacy and you
know it when you have it and you know it
when you're experienced it I
experiencing it I think that we are
experiencing new kinds of intimacy that
are wonderful the most obvious example
is probably skype you know to have a
skype conversation with somebody is
different and it's got its own potential
partly because you're able to have this
visual experience at a distance that's
unlike other visual experiences we've
had in the past as human beings it opens
up possibilities that I think we're just
beginning to discover weirdly enough I
find in some ways Twitter to be a new
kind of intimacy that's sort of exciting
to be you know intimate as much of the
day as you want at 140 characters a shot
with those X hundred or thousand people
who are your followers is really wild
it's sort of this new space that you're
in with just those people exchanging
short thoughts and they can go to
fascinating places you know so I think
there's new kinds of intimacy emerging
but they haven't changed the essence of
what intimacy is which is I'm really
having a connection with another people
or a group of people that is special
that's a true connection that's taking
me to a place that I want to go to and
it's valuable to me and so in that sense
I think we're also learning that there
are some ways in which the technologies
pretend to offer intimacy but don't and
this is something we experienced in my
family over the years and I write about
this in the book at some length where
the kinds of intimacy you typically have
in a home with parents and a child was
being sacrificed because of all the time
we were spending at the screen the three
of us my wife and I have one son who's
12 and we were turning our backs to each
other you know during private time at
home on the weekends and so forth when
we should really have been facing each
other and spending quality time the kind
of intimacy we traditionally associate
with families we don't want to give all
that up to the screen I think and so
there is screen togetherness that
families are enjoying obviously but it's
not the same thing so you need it again
healthy balance is my mantra so what we
did as a solution is we we began
unplugging on the weekends we started an
experiment it's now over three years ago
where we do what we call the internet
Sabbath